facing kyle gibson
gibson overall 29 starts this is the
29th of the season he's 10-8 with a 3.51
era
and a strike three called on the inside
corner he came in with the two seamer to
get him looking
reynolds had trouble with that pitch
last night against aaron nola and it's a
one two three first
sam howard makes his first career start
after 45 big league relief appearances
the left-hander from cartersville
georgia he's out in front of herrera
owen two herrera hit the ball the other
way foul
and a swing and a miss and he strikes
him out
with that slider
one up and one down one ball two strike
pitch on its way
and a bad looking swing and a miss and a
pitch in the dirt
by segura back-to-back case to start sam
howard's night
look at the hard fight down and in at
the back foot of gene good play by perez
too to keep that ball in front of it
the 2-2
strike three calls
he just struck out the side
well that's
bryce did not think that was a strike
obviously
[Applause]
there's kyle gibson nice bulletin a gap
here kyle
hello balls well out toward left field
gamble's going back it is gone
kyle gibson a solo home run
he's taking matters into his own hands
i don't even know if he knows he's
supposed to acknowledge the bullpen
that's going to be a smile that can last
a lifetime
for any starting pitcher the chance to
go yard
[Applause]
is a luxury and that's his first major
league home run
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and hit through and reynolds with a base
hit
big 3-1 pitch to moran coming up
and it's on its way and it's taken for
ball four and two aboard for ben gamel
now gibson's one of the better guys at
getting a ground ball so you know what
gives here
oh my god
that's what james hoy said nice
are you kidding me
i'm surprised that's only the seventh
battery here i would have guessed more
lying dry base hit into left center
field
and mccutchen
bobbles it and that will allow
the second run to score without a play
and it's a two run double for kevin
newman laced it into left center field
scoring reynolds and moran gamel to
third 2-1 pirates the lefty-hitter perez
and a base hit
gamel is in newman will score
two run single michael perez the pirates
have scored four in the fourth
they're trying to keep working uh
working down with slow stuff away
so it's difficult to get out and hook it
they know what he's trying to do because
of the defense they're playing
brad miller flied out to center his
first time up
that ball's drilled out toward right
field it is gone
solo home run for brad miller number 20
of the year
we have seen that
[Applause]
you know rare lefty that can get to that
high pitch like that up and away man did
he get to that one left ankle soreness
for adobo herrera matt bierling is in
and a liner down the left field line
that's going to be in for a base hit
beerling can run he's going to sprint
out to second base and he's there easily
with a one-out double
let's see what they do with harper bryce
is over two tonight one ball one strike
line drive out toward right field and it
is off the glove on one hop and out
toward
the spot where the right fielders
tsutsuga was standing it's an rvi double
for bryce harper
it's a 4-3 game
all right so this is where sucho was
standing look how far back josh pointed
that out with segora up
yeah he looked like he took a step to
his
to his right but never didn't come in
like that ball folding
3-0
and cuts takes and that is low ball four
how about that
off the end of the bat out towards
second off the glove of park mccutchen's
on his way to third
it'll be first and third with nobody out
one goes right through the five hole
here comes mccutchen he's going to score
it's a 4-4 game all right well te reyes
was the hero last night with is a
three-run pitch at homer
nice little line drive over the second
baseman's head that's all we need
nice little line drive out toward left
center field that'll drop for a hit the
phillies will take the lead
ronald torrez comes through again
it's 5-4
i hope it stays
rolled to second
safe
park beats it out
great shot by park that was a heck of a
play on defense too and defoe is going
to come up to pinch him
did he left one out over the bedding
[Applause]
with a pitch hit two-run home run to put
the pirates back on top
[Applause]
hanging breaking ball that's been kind
of the bad pitch of the night hasn't it
that one then the belt high curve ball
gone
and the 3-1 pitch
low ball four the lead off batters
aboard
and the payoff pitch
pulled on the ground toward third slowly
up the line it is a fair ball and it's a
thing of beauty
it puts runners at first and second with
two outs and dede gregorius is the
hitter
right field going back on it is
gone
deeney has done it a three-run home run
and the phillies have retaken the lead
here in the bottom of the seventh inning
eight to six phils
they can upset your stomach and they
cure it all at once it's
unbelievable the payoff pitch
inside ball four the bases are loaded
for key brian hayes
joe's going out
[Applause]
yeah this is i'm just saying this has
got to be just a breather i can't
imagine they bring rosso in to face keep
ryan hayes
here's hector i got it i got it i like
it i do too
back toward the middle flanked down by
hector look at him celebrate as he goes
to the back all by himself
it's a two-handed slam on the bag
you love the emotion from hector neris
to get through this inning
the 2-1 pitch to newman
fly ball center field jankowski has it
sized up he's under it makes the catch
and the ball game is over the phil's
pull to within a game of the atlanta
braves and the national league east
as they reach
80 wins on the season with an 8-6
victory
over the pittsburgh pirates